Oh this morning we're going
to do something a little
bit different which is I
thought that everyone was ready for a
break so we're going to have a guest
lecture this morning and I thought it
was particularly important that at some
point we give you a perspective from
the clinical point of view and so I'm
introducing to your doctor Margaret Craven
and I'll just say a couple of things
about her.
She's an ob Gyn and so for about 30 years
she was involved in the trenches and
the war against Hiv aids and she's going
to talk to us this morning about HIV
aids in this country.
As I said last time and that's about all
I wanted to say except one other detail
which is that she's also my wife.
Hmm.
AIDS is fundamentally different than
any other emerging global pandemic
preceding it because of the high velocity
of it spread around the world and of
the race to understand and control it.
I have given you a handout which
is a copy of the 1981 m m w R,
which stands for morbidity and mortality
weekly report of the Centers for
disease control in Atlanta.
The CDC was founded in 1946 to control
malaria and is now part of the Department
of Health and Human Services.
The MMWR is their fast track method
of publishing a medical article.
This is basically so that clinicians
can be up to speed on things.
One one report is from Los Angeles about
cases of pneumocystis pneumonia is in
gay men and the same issue.
There was also a report from New York
City about a rare cancer called Kaposi's
sarcoma and gay men.
Imagine that you're working in the field
of public health and our reading this.
The front page describes five cases of
men between the ages of 29 and 36 all of
them are gay and all have a rare lung
infection called pneumocystis pneumonia.
The back page of the report
has an editorial note
explaining what it is as it is
so rare that nobody would
ever have heard of it.
The article was the starting gun for
a sprint on the part of the medical
community.
Within three years of this
publication by the CDC,
the human immunodeficiency virus
was identified as the cause of AIDS.
The emerging epidemic of our times.
It is even more fragile fest is m
minuscule than the bacteria that causes
syphilis or gonorrhea,
but it is spread the same way through
the intimate exchange of bodily fluids.
How did HIV such a
powerful and widespread killer in
such a short time causing the present
worldwide pandemic of around 33
million infected individuals?
How is it left?
More than 25 million of us dead
and 14 million children orphaned?
Why did it still in fact,
about 2.7 million of us in the year 2007
and kill to 2 million people that year?
Certain historical background
conditions made this tragedy possible.
Globalization,
invasive medical technology,
especially blood transfusions and
migration and concentration of gay men.
Globalization is a phenomenon that's
been gathering momentum are ever since
Christopher Columbus length,
the two hemispheres.
I think you've heard about
the Columbian exchange.
Many thinkers have written about it.
I quote one of them.
The need of a constantly expanding market
for its products chases the Boers Waze
over the whole surface of the globe. It
must nessel everywhere. Settle everywhere,
established connections everywhere.
The Boris was,
he has through its exploitation
of the world market,
given a cosmopolitan
character to production and
consumption in every country to
the great chagrin of reactionists.
It has drawn from under
the feet of the industry,
the national ground on which it stood.
All old,
established national industries have
been destroyed or daily being destroyed.
They are dislodged by new industries whose
introduction becomes a life and death
question for all civilized nations
by industries that no longer work up
indigenous raw material, but raw
material drawn from the remotest zones.
You may have recently heard about
the tanker on the Australian reef.
It was going to China
in the streets whose products
are consumed not only at home,
but in every corner of the
globe and place of the old want,
satisfied by the
productions of the country.
We find new wants requiring
for their satisfaction,
the products of distant lands and climbs
in place of the old local and national
seclusion and self sufficiency.
We have intercourse in every direction.
Universal interdependence of nations.
Yeah.
Who Do you think wrote this?
Okay.
Could it be Tom Friedman?
He'll frequently contributes to the New
York Times and writes extensively on
globalization.
How about Adam Smith or Carl Marx?
Both very famous political economists
have earlier centuries or is it Jose
[inaudible],
a French farmer who organized the peaceful
remove or of Mcdonald's from his town
in France?
I quote wants more.
The Boers was he during its rule of
scarce 100 years has created more massive
and more colossal productive forces than
have all preceding generations together.
Subjection of nature's
courses to man machinery,
application of chemistry to industry
and agriculture, steam navigation,
railways, electric telegraphs, clearing
and hold continents for cultivation,
cannibalization of rivers,
whole populations conjured
out of the ground.
What earlier century had
even a present moment.
There's such productive forces lumbered
it in the lack of social labor,
modern bourgeois society with its
relations of production of exchange and a
property.
A society that has conjured
up such gigantic means of
production and of exchange
is like the sorcerer who is no longer
able to control the powers of the
Netherworld whom he has
called up by his spells.
It sounds like this profit,
Karl Marx speaking from the mid 19th
century would not have been surprised to
learn that at an even faster
mode of transportation,
air travel has been invented.
It now links all the continents of the
globe so that we can wake up in Africa
and go to bed and Canada.
This enabled one good looking French,
Canadian gay and very
promiscuous airlines steward,
so called patient zero to be instrumental
and spreading the aids epidemic
throughout North America.
The same forces also gave birth to a
growing science and technology that from
the underpinnings forum and
the underpinnings of modern
biomedical research and
Western medicine.
Let's reminisce about the good
old days and the 1970s pre aids.
I was at an Obg Ryan resident and
remembered that the medical profession was
full of optimism and hope.
A positive rather complacent attitude was
instilled in us medical students about
what hardworking well dockers
would be able to accomplish.
We would be able to fix the body's
mechanical defects with needles, tubes,
surgeries and blood products,
syphilis, TB, cholera,
and the other bacterial diseases
would be eliminated with antibiotics.
Vaccinations could cure a long list
of awful diseases like smallpox,
polio, diphtheria, tetanus, and on and on.
Globalization of medicine in the
World Health Organization would make
eradication of these diseases
from the entire globe possible.
Here's the world health,
the OP,
a whore organization's optimistic
de definition of health.
Back in those days,
ambitious scientist and doctors
were busy competing for grants,
positions of prestigious laboratories
and prizes like the Nobel prize.
The surgeon general of the United
States announced rather arrogantly.
In 1976 we have turned the
page on infectious diseases.
This smug medical attitudes
suddenly disappeared in the
1980s when our community
was confronted with a totally new
and mysterious emerging pandemic.
Where did it come from?
How did it start?
I highly recommend to you a book named
the river written by an Englishman Edward
Hooper,
who tries to answer these very questions.
The authors of Oud role model is Dr. John
Snow, the first modern epidemiologist.
He wrote a book about tracking down the
sorts of Colorado through the London
water supply in 1849 that you've
probably covered that in the course.
Like Snow Hooper has done an exhaustive
investigation of every available source
of knowledge
relating to the emergence of the AIDS
epidemic instead of one city. However,
he has had to trace the
epidemic up to three continents.
His story starts in the United States
with the first reported cases from the CDC
that you have there and traces the
chain of infection backwards in time.
Hooper agrees with Randy Shilts who wrote
the aids classic and the band played
on.
Um,
both think that the beginning of the
epidemic here was probably July 4th,
1976 to celebrate the
bicentennial of our nation.
New York City hosted the tall ships.
Huge sailing ships came from all
over the world and there was a lot of
international party and
going on in the big apple.
Retrospectively,
studies revealed that the first American
babies who were HIV positive were born
in New York City. A year later, 1977
hooper story then moves to Haiti.
The refugees seeking asylum here seem
to have a horrifyingly high incidence of
HIV.
And as a result,
many Americans went through a phase of
scapegoating Haitian refugees as the
sorts of aids.
Papa doc had a brutal regime that ruled
Haiti from 1957 to 1971 by means of
violent death squads called
the Tom Tom Macoute. Therefore,
when the Belgian Congo in Africa
became independent from Belgium in 1960
thousands of French
speaking professionals, uh,
escape their oppressive government
by taking jobs in the Congo,
in addition to help solve as
economic problems in Haiti,
Papa doc promoted his capital as a
tourist attraction for gay men from North
America and Germany.
Haiti was not the only country linking
the chain of infection back to the
Belgian count colonies in Africa.
The epicenter of the disease is found
where Congo, Rwanda, Burundi, and Uganda,
nick come together by standard
epidemiologic logic, uh, detective work.
This is a picture of a refugee camp
that is a right in that area were aids
originated.
Okay.
How it started is a much
more controversial issue.
Hooper finds extremely compelling,
the hypothesis that an oral polio vaccine
tested an African in 1958 in the very
place that is now the epicenter of
the disease may have enabled as Simian
immunosuppressive virus to cross
species from chimps to humans.
This hypothesis path is,
is,
is one among several about how the Simian
Immune virus could have mutated into a
human disease. Of course, there's no
ethical way of proving any of them,
so we will never actually
know what happened.
Yeah.
Anyhow,
back to what we know for sure.
Another background condition responsible
for the rapid spread of AIDS are the
tools of modern western medicine,
hypodermic needles, blood banking,
and invasive surgical techniques.
One of the first cases of recognized
aids occurred in a Danish surgeon named
Gretta Rask who had gone to work in the
Congo in 1964 she worked for three years
in a rural hospital that often had
no surgical gloves doing her surgery.
Barehanded.
She fell ill in 1976 eventually having
to fly back to Denmark under emergency
conditions and died there in 1977
as we saw from the CDC report,
the pneumocystis pneumonia that she had
was a rare opportunistic infection that
only occurs in people with severe
compromise of their immune systems.
According to close friends,
she had no other possible
route of infection than
performing surgery because she
would sell a bit and basically
spent her whole life working.
Yeah,
hemophilia axle.
Also,
we're one of the first groups noted to
have this new disease because they needed
to use pool. The factor eight to
prevent bleeding. At that time,
factory was used from concentrated,
pooled the CRM for many units of donated
blood and by 1984 50% of hemophilia
acts were HIV positive.
Okay.
And of course the tools of medicine don't
stay locked in offices and hospitals.
Needles made their way onto the
street for shooting the heroin.
A globalized mafia was,
uh, making available.
Ivy drug use also preceded the arrival
of HIV in New York at the 4th of July.
Celebration in 1976 IVD use that stands
for intravenous drug users soon became
one of the high risk groups for
aids and along with hemophilia x.
Let's take off that ugly picture.
The fourth factor in the rapid spread
of the epidemic was a migration and
concentration of gay men
in certain locations.
How and why did this happen?
Let's go back in time to the
middle of the 20th century.
The Nazi regime in Germany reveal to
the world how big a tree intolerance,
racism, and super nationalism can
grow into a grotesque, violent,
terrifying political machine of
Ostracism, slavery, and extermination.
Yeah.
In Hitler's Germany,
homosexuals were forced to wear a pink
triangle on their clothes and were sent
to concentration camps along with Jews,
communists, disabled people, and Gypsies.
I'm sorry to say that the Nazis are not
the first and last people in the world
to be bigoted in Hollerin and racist.
When American fighting men came
back home from World War II,
blacks went back to the segregated south.
Jews were excluded,
excluded from social clubs
and not long afterward,
Senator Joe McCarthy and FBI Director,
j Edgar Hoover took on
communists and homosexuals,
the police in many large
cities and trapped men and
bathrooms by propositioning
them and immediately arresting
them if they responded.
Okay.
The usual punishment was not jail,
but notification of the
employer and public humiliation.
Yeah.
Alan Turing, a mathematical
genius who had cracked. Um,
the Nazi submarine code was arrested,
tried and convicted under Britain's
anti homosexual statutes in 1952,
he committed suicide in the summer of
1954 by taking a bite of a cyanide laced
apple in his laboratory.
Okay.
What do people do when they're living
a life of harassment and persecution?
They look for a place to go
where they will be accepted,
cared for and left alone.
That's ghettos form.
Even without state decree.
After the war,
people who were ostracizing and harass
back in their hometowns began to seek the,
I'm an anonymity of big cities.
A gay communities sprang up in Greenwich
village in New York and other developed
as a summer vacation spot
on fire island in the 60s.
It was illegal to serve
openly gay men at a bar.
Radical Gay Power and liberation was
launched with the Stonewall Inn riot the
last weekend of June,
1969 when a gay bar was raided by the
NYP D and drag queens bought back.
However,
the apogee,
the apogee of political sec success
for gays was achieved not in New York,
but in San Francisco.
Okay.
Harvey milk was elected as a supervisor,
the first openly gay elected
official in the nation.
And some of you may have
seen the recent movie, uh,
the film that was named a milk,
which is about his story.
In 1978, right? And City Hall,
Harvey Milk and the Liberal Mayor George
Mouse gone were shot by another member
of the board of supervisors,
the Anti Anti Gay politician,
Dan White. Instantly.
Harvey milk became a martyr,
galvanizing gay solidarity by 1980.
The then governor of
California, Edmond Brown, um,
declared the last week in June,
Gay Freedom Week.
This is the week of Gay
Freedom Day parades all over
the world commemorating the
stonewall riot.
As a result,
San Francisco became a Mecca
for gay people who's trained
there in great numbers.
I quote Randy Schultz in and the band
played on the promise of freedom had
fueled the greatest exodus of
immigrants to San Francisco.
Since the gold rush between 1969 and
1973 at least 9,000 gay men move to San
Francisco,
followed by 20,000.
Between 1974 and 1978 by 1980
about 5,000 homosexual man,
we're moving to the
golden gate every year.
The immigration now made for a city
in which two and five adult males were
openly gay.
This group was a very
politically coherent.
They were thrilled to come out of
the closet and participate openly.
Gay People started their own
churches and choirs. As a result,
local charities like the Red Cross,
we're happy to exploit
their civic mindedness.
In 1985 to 7% of the donated blood in San
Francisco was given by gay men who did
not know that they were HIV positive.
Okay.
Of course,
immigrant groups,
I'll always have their seamier side of
organized crime and our end up commercial
sex. Gay Men in particular were accustomed
to covert and anonymous expression of
their sexuality and participation in the
bath house culture was more mainstream
for them.
Remember,
many of these young men had
been repressing and hiding
their sexuality for most
of their lives. And when society, they'd
denies people healthy ways of expressing,
expressing their sexuality, all kinds
of strange things begin to happen.
Many of the strange things that happened
in the bath houses are perfect methods
of transmitting every kind of infection,
especially hepatitis B,
g already a salmonella and
something brand new HIV.
Um, and if you don't know
what the bath houses are,
I would recommend that you read Shanti
Randy Shilts, his book and find out.
So this is the background of AIDS,
globalization,
modern invasive medical technology,
and ghettoizing of gay people.
Okay,
let's return to 1981 and the first report
in the medical literature that you all
have in your hands.
Western doctors who read it were oblivious
to the fact that while everyone is
celebrating like World Health
Organization's successful
program to eradicate
smallpox in 1978 [inaudible] stealthy
brand new germ had spread from central
Africa via professionals who had
worked there to both Haiti in Europe.
It had been introduced to centers of
commercialized gay sex once it had spread
into the blood banks and hospitals of
every nation and to intravenous drug users
and into their partners in babies.
Of course,
when the first horrible deaths from
weird infections occurred in the late
seventies and early eighties doctors
had no idea that the cause of this
mysterious immunological
deficiency was a retro virus,
that it was a slow virus and had been
contracted up to 10 years before.
The first characteristic of the disease
observant doctors noticed was it's
typical STD pattern.
It affected exactly the same high risk
groups that syphilis and hepatitis B
affect gay men,
prostitutes of both sexes,
intravenous drug users,
and hemophiliacs.
This epidemiological pattern caused
instant recognition in the minds of the
knowledgeable.
They immediately knew that this was an
infectious disease caused by a virus and
bodily fluids.
That's why the first report submitted in
1981 were published immediately in the
MMWR.
Take another look at the paper yourself.
So imagine reading it and instantly
predicting the awful future.
Luckily for all of us,
Dr Don Francis Man and
the sweater did just that.
He was a 38 year old,
the epidemiologist who was at the
time working with the gay community on
developing a hepatitis B vaccine. His, uh,
phd project and lab work had been on
retroviruses on hearing about these two
reports. He instantly put two and two
together to predict that this was a virus
responsible for immunosuppressant and
to predisposing to cancers as well as
opportunistic infections.
By just the year before,
in 1980 doctor Robert Gallo of the
National Cancer Institute had shown that a
retrovirus he called htlv cause a
type of leukemia common in Japan.
It was contagious and had a
frighteningly long incubation period.
Dr. Francis at the CDC
understood immediately in
1981 what sort of a disaster
was in the making.
And so right away he began trying to
move heaven and earth to get money for
recent search for virus
labs to isolate and uh,
the virus and get a diagnostic test.
But his please fell mostly on deaf ears.
A few did eventually pay attention
to him luckily and a year later,
Doctor Gallo at the NCI was finally
convinced the Dr. Francis was right and
dedicated a portion of his lab,
the research meanwhile and France,
Professor Luc Montagnier Aa of the Pastor
Institute and in San Francisco j Levy.
We're also working on
trying to isolate the virus.
The French isolated at first and soon
afterwards applied to the patent office in
the United States for a blood test.
Gallows lab announced in 1984 that they
had discovered the aids infectious agent
applied to also for a patent and tried
to take all the credit for the discovery.
This led to an unpleasant
and embarrassing squabble,
the squabble between France and the U s
we always seem to be getting into little
squabbles with them.
Finally,
after lawsuits, congressional
investigations in public apologies,
everyone agreed on a way to
share a settlement negotiated
1987 named mom 10 Yay
and Gallo is co-discoverers and divided
the royalties from the blood tests
between an aids foundation,
the Nih and the pastor institute.
The 2008 Nobel prize in medicine went
to doctor Montagnais for his discovery.
As you can see, it is he who
is smiling, not doctor Gallo,
mom,
10 yeas and gallows efforts had produced
the diagnostic Elisa blood test by 1984
this had enormous implications of course
for the blood banking ends it industry.
It also meant that populations could be
screened to find out who was infected
naturally.
Epidemiologist wanted to screen the high
risk populations to find out the actual
extent of the epidemic.
They wanted it to do what epidemiologists
always do try to contain the disaster
by identifying carriers and their contacts
and by preventing the spread of the
infection.
Unfortunately,
they knew that trying to work with
the two high risk groups, Msms,
that's men who have sex with men
and Ivd us was not going to be easy.
As an example,
gay time Douga the Canadian Airlines,
Stewart who is known as patient zero
estimated he had approximately 250 sexual
partners per year and carried on
like that for longer than 10 years.
Busy Guy,
the hotline at the Kaposi
Sarcoma Foundation began
receiving repeated calls from
people who had had sex in a sex parlor
with a Frenchman and he then calmly told
them that he had gay
cancer or Kaposi's sarcoma.
This is gay town Douga
and this is what one of the
signs of Kaposi's sarcoma.
As a result,
the director of the San Francisco Public
Health Department had to confront him
with the consequences of his behavior.
His pithy response to her was,
it's none of your goddamn business.
It's my right to do what I wanted to do
with my own body. If I was totally cool,
I would say that with a French accent,
but I'm not.
Next to the exact mechanisms of
pathogenesis were worked out.
HIV was shown to be
transmitted by sexual contact,
from exposure to infected blood or from
an infected mother to her fetus are
breastfed infant,
although the paranoid public thought
that you could get it from door knobs and
toilet seats.
Once the virus gained
access to the new host,
it would target lymphocytes in the blood
with the CD four cell surface molecule.
After gaining entry to these
important cells in the immune system.
Since the virus is cytopathic and
cell killing, it would replicate,
kill the cell and release into
the bloodstream causing a virus.
Emea of billions of particles.
Researchers discovered that they could,
uh,
course follow the course of the disease
by counting CD four cells more recently.
Um,
the ability to measure viral loads
directly has also become possible.
And so this is presently a routine means
of monitoring the course of disease and
the impact of treatments
and healthy people CD four counselor
over 500 cells per millimeter cubed.
And when the count drops under 200,
the person experiences significant
immunodeficiency so that their body cannot
fight off opportunistic
infections like TB,
pneumocystis pneumonia
or PCP as it's called,
toxoplasmosis and cryptococcal meningitis.
Here's a chart showing the most common
presenting complaints in a Haitian clinic
leading to a diagnosis of AIDS.
You can see that 54% presented with TB,
sorry. Yeah. Extra
pulmonary and pulmonary TB.
10% were diagnosed as part of pregnancy
screening and the third largest group
had what was called slim disease,
which is basically wasting away.
Yeah.
Once the pathogenesis was understood,
uh,
at strategies for treatment
could be developed.
This is consisted of
three prongs of attack,
one aggressive treatment and prevention
of the opportunistic infections that
ravage the bodies of immunocompromised
people to antiretrovirals and,
and more recently protease inhibitors.
That's lots of pills.
The invention I'm antiretroviral agents
began with Azt introduced in 1987 since
then, more than 14 have
been approved by the FDA,
the food and Drug Administration,
which is incredibly fast approval.
Usually the FDA is very slow and
deliberate about approving new drugs.
However, because of intense
pressure from gay activists like up,
the rules were changed for
Aids medications in 1994
the pediatric AIDS clinical
trial group protocol showed that AZT
taken during pregnancy could significantly
reduce the vertical transmission
of HIV from mother to baby.
There's also from evidence now that
drug's given after exposure for medical
workers,
rape victims or other unprotected
sex offers a good hope of prevention.
This is called postexposure prophylaxis
and the most recent discovery
is that circumcision offers
some protection to men.
Okay.
And the space of seven years from the
first reported cases in 1981 of agonizing
deaths in young gay men,
the scientific medical establishment
was able to unravel the mystery of the
disease and start treating it.
However,
because of globalization and because
of cultural attitudes towards sex that
we'll talk about,
HIV AIDS had already spread around the
entire world within those seven years and
was duck decimating sub Saharan Africa.
Okay.
Since 1987 tremendous strides have been
made in wealthy countries and treating
the disease with complicated and
expensive multiple drug regiments.
Recommendations from a
CDC panel in 2002 state
antiretroviral regimens are complex,
have serious side effects,
post difficulty with adherence and Carrie
serious potential consequences from
the development of viral
resistance because of non
adherence to the drug regimen
or suboptimal levels of
anti retroviral agents.
Patient involvement in
therapeutic decisions is critical.
Yeah,
it's a full time job being HIV positive,
just keeping track of your medications.
These treatments cost well over $1,500
a month and turn aids into a chronic
illness. Most of the people
in the world, however,
are too poor to have access to these
expensive drugs and complex healthcare
interactions.
The majority of people with aids waste
away and die between the ages of 25 and
44 without the benefit
of any medical care.
Despite millions of dollars
and years of trying.
All attempts at developing a vaccine
have been dismal failures so far.
Yeah,
but this is basically an STD,
isn't it? What about prevention?
Yeah,
we all know that STDs are
potentially preventable,
so why wasn't something done at
the beginning of the epidemic?
Why did the world wait around for science
to be worked out before going into
action to do something about the disaster?
You can bet that all smart medical
personnel like this lovely nurse instantly
put on gloves,
gowns,
and and instituted universal precautions,
which is the modern day a quarantine.
Why didn't everybody else
put on their condoms?
Our culture greeted the news of this
frightening new disease with the same old
counterproductive reactions of the past.
Scapegoating mass hysteria,
uh,
and the public was given a front
row seat by modern mass media to the
confrontation between the religious
right led by people like Reverend Jerry
Falwell and his moral majority
and organized gays like act up.
It was even more exciting
than professional wrestling
when the media and the
public realized however,
that unsuspecting patients were
being infected by the blood supply.
People with AIDS were ostracized.
Hemophilia children were
prevented from attending school.
Haitian immigrants were
excluded from the country.
People were afraid to donate blood.
They associated walking into a blood
bank with catching the disease.
But when Rock Hudson,
a movie star icon of male charisma
at the time announced he had aids.
And died of it in 1985 the American media
and its adoring public finally decided
we'd better get serious about all of this.
[inaudible]
old religious ideas about sexuality took
on fresh meaning suddenly everyone be
going, I'm talking about
celibacy, monogamy and abstinence.
The sixties and seventies had been a time
of liberalization of old sexual mores
in Western civilizations with the
invention of the birth control pill,
legalized abortion and
effective treatments for STDs.
Many religious fundamentalists
had been very unhappy.
Now they could climb into their
puppets and preach fire and brimstone.
Jerry Falwell, a Baptist
minister, pronounced
[inaudible]
aids is not just God's
punishment for homosexuals.
It is God's punishment for the
society that tolerates homosexuals.
The Roman Catholic Church ruled by the
pope from the Holy See at the Vatican is
an absolute monarch made a
response through its global
government of bishops in
parish priests.
The Catholic church also condemn home
homosexuality and since the Catholic
church is opposed to all birth control,
the use of condoms is also condemned.
Yeah,
the gay community has a particular
interest in the Catholic Church.
They suspect that many who have taken a
vow of celibacy may actually be closet
homosexuals
as a result of decision was made by the
gay community to hold their world pride,
celebration and Rome and the year 2000
this was especially maddening because the
late Pope John Paul,
the second and the Vatican had mobilized
tremendous resources to celebrate the
2000 years of Christianity.
The jubilee,
the Church tried pressuring the Italian
government to remove its support for the
gay pride demonstration. The pope
appeared to make the following statement
and the name of the Church of Rome.
I must express sadness for the, uh,
front to the grand jubilee of the year
2004 the offense to the Christian values
of the city that is so dear to the
hearts of the Catholics of the world.
Homosexual acts are against nature's laws.
The church cannot silence
the truth because this would
not help discern what is
good and what is evil.
Before aids emerged in the United States,
right wing religious groups
had organized politically,
politically around antiabortion agendas.
This group would chooses the buzzwords
right to life and family values was
already up and running with big cloud
on the Republican Party's platform.
They had helped to elect the conservative
California governor President
Ronald Reagan in 1980
he was in the White House,
busy slashing the healthcare budget
when the aids tragedy unfolded.
A disease of gay men and drug
users was not a priority for him
at a time that called for
strong leadership to contain
a major emerging epidemic.
Our president chose to remain oblivious
to the insistent demands of the CDC and
gay rights groups to be proactive about
preventing the spread of suffering.
In addition,
he had instituted the gag rule,
which effectively defunded the United
Nations Population Fund the largest backer
in the world of women's
reproductive health.
The clinics where poor people get condoms.
When President Reagan nominated doctor
c Everett Koop to be his surgeon general
feminist gaze and pro choice
groups were worried because of the,
this pediatric surgeon from Philadelphia
had a reputation for an anti choice
agenda.
Okay.
I'm only five years into the epidemic.
President Reagan responded to mounting
pressure by asking doctor coop to prepare
a report on AIDS.
Doctor Coop is a great guy.
He's a good hardworking doctor and he
got busy for the next nine months doing a
thorough and honest job
investigating the epidemic.
He ended up writing a lot of the report
by himself to the medical professions
delight. The report was
explicit, nonjudgmental,
controversial and popular.
It contributed significantly to providing
accurate comprehensive information to
the public coop.
Also personally penned understanding aids,
the public health,
a brochure.
He made the decision to send the brochure
to all 107 a million US households in
1988 the largest public help mailing ever.
Yeah,
and rumor had it at the time
that President Reagan and
didn't find out about it
until after, after he got
his in the mail. I guess
aside from Dr. Cooper,
however,
the Reagan administration had two
political agendas that could not have been
more inimical to containing the epidemic.
The statistics speak for themselves.
Instead of providing more funding to
the government's health agencies to deal
with the problem, the administration
was slashing budgets. In addition,
they blocked the efforts of sex educators
worldwide around STD prevention,
the so called gag rule.
The large groups of people who believe
in preventive medicine began lobbying
hard for good sex education
and PR for condom use.
But Republicans and the religious
right have consistently tried to block
providing this education in public
schools and on TV while legislating
abstinence only, uh, education, uh,
to which billions of
dollars had been given.
The Gay Community of course,
educated themselves about safer sex,
but they blocked the closing down of
the bath houses for an unconscionable
amount of time.
Another preventative strategy strategy
that can tremendously slow the spread of
HIV is needle exchange programs.
IVD use intravenous drug users reused
dirty needles and countries that provide
sterile needles in
exchange for dirty ones.
The spread of disease among this
group slows dramatically. However,
in the United States,
these programs have been blocked
by the religious right
[inaudible].
One of the most depressingly shortsighted
responses to the epidemic was that of
the blood banking industry.
The Food and Drug Administration is
the federal agency that regulates them,
but politics prevented them
from doing the right thing.
Dr. Francis and the CDC, we're
desperately trying to convince the FDA,
the Red Cross,
the American Association of Blood Banks,
the national hemophilia foundation
to institutes screening and blood for
hepatitis B. Even before the
blood test for HIV had been, uh,
invented because gay men had cooperated
in the research for a vaccine against
hepatitis B,
it was clear to everyone that the
same people at risk for one disease,
we're at risk for the other.
But the gay groups were absolutely
paranoid about screening of any kind.
They featured,
they feared the stigma of positive
blood test would affect their,
uh, would make them lose
their job in their insurance.
And the blood banking industry was very
happy to go along with the gay lobby
because it would be so expensive and
such a big deal for them to screen the
blood.
Therefore,
even though Don Frances was openly
accusing them of negligent homicide,
the Red Cross did nothing until 1985
when the screening test for HIV became
available. Prior to this,
babies needing transfusions,
grandmothers needing hip replacements,
haemophiliacs their wives and
many others had died. Premature,
prolonged and painful deaths from
the contaminated blood supply.
Once blood testing became routine,
politically organized,
gay groups successively
got irrationally stringent.
Confidentiality laws passed around the
screening test and those regulations
haven't had a negative impact on
collecting accurate statistics ever since.
Okay.
Luckily not all reaction to the aids
crisis were based on intolerance,
political expediency, financial
short sightedness and self interest.
Many nurses, doctors, families
and friends of victims,
ministers and rabbis rallied
around to provide support,
to organize fundraising to apply
political pressure and countless acts of
compassion and charity.
A heart rending and beautiful reminder
of this is the aids quilt which is part
of the names project.
Their stated goals are to provide a
creative means for remembrance and healing
to illustrate the enormity
of the AIDS epidemic,
to increase public awareness of AIDS,
to assist with HIV prevention education
and to raise funds for community based
AIDS service organizations.
Anyone can commemorate someone who died
of AIDS by making a panel of the quilt,
which is a size of a gravestone
three feet by six feet with the name,
the dates in any memorabilia on it.
A documentary about the project called
common threads won an academy award in
1990 and is available for you to watch
an October of 1996 the aids quilt
was unfurled in Washington DC.
It was a mile long extending from the
Washington monument to Capitol Hill.
I just want to say it's a little
different living through an epidemic than
reading about it.
Many thoughtful religious people were
jolted into reexamining their proper role
in this crisis with regards
to human sexuality and health.
The Episcopal Bishop of Newark,
New Jersey,
John Shelby Spong became famous with
the press and the 1980s because of his
active role in ordaining gay priests
in his work against homophobia.
He, along with others formed a task force
on changing patterns in sexuality and
family life to examine changes in modern
society and to make recommendations for
study for the National
Episcopal Convention in 1987
the task force recommended
in relation to premarital sexual
activity that all relationships are to be
assessed in terms of their capacity
to manifest marks of the realm of God,
healing, reconciliation, compassion,
mutuality and concern for
others both within and beyond.
Once immediate circle of intimacy with
regard to issues of committed homosexual
relationships.
The report suggested that ideally
homosexual couples would find within the
community of the faithful the congregation
the same recognition and affirmation
which nurtures and sustains heterosexual
couples and their relationships,
including where appropriate,
liturgies which recognize and
blessed such relationships.
Many religious people were eager to become
a source of encouragement and healing
instead of guilt and shame for the myriad
of people who do not fit into narrowly
defined unrealistic sexual roles.
Reactions to the AIDS epidemic has caused
ongoing struggles within traditional
religions around the issue
of gay relationships and
premarital sex education.
And this continued into the new millennium
three days after the tragedy of nine 11
the Reverend Jerry Falwell pronounced on
the 700 club,
the Christian TV show.
I really believe that the Pagans and the
abortionists and the feminists and the
gays and the lesbians that are actively
trying to make an alternative lifestyle,
the ACL,
you people for the American way,
all of them who have tried
to secularize America,
I point the finger in their face and say,
you helped this happen.
CNN set up and took notice of this
and gave the executive director of the
National Gay and Lesbian Task
Force and opportunity to respond.
She answered by saying the terrible
tragedy that has befallen our nation and
indeed the entire global community
is the sad byproduct of fanaticism.
It has its roots in the same fanaticism
that enables people like Jerry Falwell
to preach hate against those who do not
think live or love and the exact same
way he does.
The tragedies that have occurred this
week did not occur because someone made
God man mad.
As Dr. Paul asserts,
they occurred because of hate,
pure and simple.
It's time to move beyond a place
of hate and to a place of healing.
We hope that Mr Falwell will apologize
to the u s and world communities
[inaudible].
The sad fact is that any one of us can
get aids in the same way that anyone can
be the victim of a terrorist.
Okay?
You don't to do anything to
deserve it. All you have to do is be
in the wrong place at the wrong time,
whether we like it or not.
In this 21st century,
we are one overgrown him and family of
more than 6.7 billion individuals packed
into a global village at the 33 million
among us who live with HIV AIDS or a
huge reservoir for all sorts of
opportunistic infections because of immune
compromise. As a result, syphilis
and TB have made a comeback.
Multiple drug resistant TB is
becoming a growing problem at present.
Our best hopes for prevention of HIV AIDS
in the future lies and unfettered the
gigs on the sex education community,
providing condoms,
supporting and promoting monogamy
regardless of sexual preference,
needle exchange programs, universal access
to family planning and prenatal care,
and then funding viral research.
Okay.
Wherever the next killer epidemic starts,
like AIDS did an Africa,
it won't take long to
infect the whole earth.
If governments in system playing politics
with the medical profession and public
health institutions,
evidence based medicine,
not religious revelation should be the
basis of decision making when it comes to
containing epidemics. Our future
relies on clever, energetic,
young people like yourself deciding that
you're not afraid of the hard work and
complicated,
unpopular truths that are an integral
part of maintaining public health.
Okay.
Here's a list of questions to get you
started thinking and talking about
sexually transmitted
diseases and public policy,
and I think you're going to
email that to them, right?
So you don't have to copy it down.
Good luck.